today we're gonna see another tutorial
about JavaScript and we're gonna create
the flappy bird game using pure
JavaScript so this tutorial will be in
two different parts the first one will
be there about the logic of the have the
game and then the part 2 will be will be
about writing the code so when I go
directly to write the code because we
have to know the logic behind everything
first now let's go and see the logic
about the game so here what we need in
html5 all we need you to create our
canvas giving us on ID and then a with
it and the height so in our web browser
in our page to look at something like
this so here is the width and here is
the height now everything else
well created using javascript to create
games we just have just have to draw
images to the canvas continuously and
unchanged in their positions so first
we're gonna select our canvas using
document dot get element by ID every
canvas and we don't have to write all
the slime every time so we're gonna set
this to a variable and then using the
get context that gives us a lot of
methods and properties that gives us us
access to the canvas to write or to draw
anything we want
and the canvas so we'll get the context
of our canvas and we said that variable
set acts context so we won't have to
write the line again now we have to load
the images first to load an image who
will save well we will give the image a
name and then we will say new the object
image and then we have to give the image
a source so we will say image name that
sirs SRC equals the MS and for example
images slash image dot PNG
and the same thing for the audio when we
when we need to toward an audio file now
to draw an image we will say set X dot
draw image function this function gets a
lot of arguments so we'll just give it
for now for the example just 5 arguments
which are the image name it's X position
X Y position its width and its height
same for example we have the bird image
then we give it 100 pixels for the
exposition and 150 pixels for the Y
position and its width it is 50 pixels
the height is 50 so here in the left in
our campus who will get something like
this so this is the Y position this is
the x position and this is the height
and this is the Winnett so our image
will be all right here to move our bird
here we just have to to change the
values of y and x positions now to draw
our images to the canvas who will use
everything inside the function called
draw so the first thing I'm gonna draw
is the background so I'm gonna sit extra
to draw image background and I'm giving
it an x position equals to zero the Y
position equals the zero and I'm not
giving it to with it and the height
because I already said all the with it
and the heart of images using Photoshop
so this line of code will give us
something like this in our canvas and
then we will say so texture draw image
now we'll draw the pipe north and the
pipe note has a pipe exposition and the
pipe Y position so we'll get something
like this and for the pipe south
remember they have the same pipe
exposition but for the pipe Y position
we will add a constant to the pipe south
so we will get something like this and
this is the constant so the constant
here is the pipe
hate plus a gap now we're going to draw
a front ground so the front ground has a
zero possession and this y position so
this is the canvas height and this is
the floor ground height and this is the
canvas height minus the foreground
height so our so our foreground will be
in this place now we're going to draw
our bird our bird has an x position and
the y position so it will be here now I
have to draw the images continually so
for that we will use a callback function
so we will use the requestanimationframe
so this function here so this function
here will call the draw function then
the draw function executes then it
called the requestanimationframe again
the request animation frame of the draw
function again and so on and this code
will be run again and again and again so
we will have to call the draw function
just once now as you remember this is
the bird Y position so our bird here
will go down by the gravity the gravity
here is a number and we increment the
parent of Y position by the number and
when our player press ok on the keyboard
the bird will goes up so we will
decrement the bird Y position so in our
code
we'll get something like this so the
bird why we will increment it by the
gravity the gravity may call to one or
two or 1.5 and on keydown event we will
decrement the Y position by 20 for
example and we can change it in our game
now for our game or we'll need a lot of
pipes so for da we'll set an array
called pipe and we will initiate this
array with this
so the x position will be the canvas
with it and do i position is zero now
inside our draw function beside the code
we already typed so we use a full loop
to loop all over the pipe array so we
will draw out the pipe not and its
position is the pipe of i dot x and it's
our position is this so we get for
example the pipe north right here
because the pipe 0 for example the x
have this x position and the pipe 0 that
y will have a 0 position and for the
pipe south it could be right here now to
move our pipes will say pipe of i dot x
minus minus so our pipe a will go from
the right to the left just like this and
now this is our canvas with that this is
for example 188 pixels so we so I want
to say here is when our pipe reaches
this position we have to add new
coordinates to our pipe array so we will
say F the pipe either x equals canvas
that with it - 188 means win our pipe
which is this place we have to push near
coordinates to our pipe again we will
say X covers the wooden so we'll create
our pipe just right here and then we
have the set and new Y position so to
set a new Y position here different Y
positions we need to use the random
function so we'll use the Mallory random
and demanded flow the method random will
gives us a number between 0 and 1 and
Method flow will gives us our we return
an integer now we need numbers between 0
so this is the maximum y position and
minus the height of this pipe so for
that we will say we will multiply our
model random by the pipe north dot
height so now we will get we will get 0
if the math around the mission zero and
we will get the pipe not the height if
the man that the random returns 1 then
we say - the pipe north that height so
in this case we'll get numbers between 0
and - the pipe night dot height and so
then we'll get new pipes for example
right here and so on when these pipes
reaches this position we'll push new
coordinates to our pipe array now let's
set our game over rules remember this is
our burned x position this is our bird Y
position and this is our burned x
position plus the belt down with it and
this is the bird Y position prosper the
height now this is the pipe x position
and this is the pipe Y position and this
is the pipe exposition plus five now
with it now this place is the pipe Y
position plus its height and here is the
pipe Y position plus the constant and
here is the cover that height minus the
foreground at height now it's a game
over F for example if our bird touches
the front of the pipe which means the
bird X plus bailed out with it is
equator than or equal today by X so this
is the first row and if our bird is in
this place and then if our bird x + bird
now with it
is less than that pipe axe that the pipe
X plus the pipe now with it and F in
this case this is the bird Y position is
less than the PI point plus pipe height
or for example in this case if the bird
y + / height is greater than the pipe y
plus the constant and the last one we
will see all if the earth wire plus the
bird height is greater than the camera
height - the FIR ground dot height so
this is it for the game over rolls now
this is the end of the logic about the
flappy bird game now let's go and write
our code now guys let's go and write our
code so in the description you will find
starter template which has some images
the background image this is its
resolution so will be our canvas and the
other images and a fly got mp3 and the
skull does mp3 and then the index dot
HTML and the flappy bird jazz for our
JavaScript code I'm gonna run my file
and they will create the compass giving
it an ID then with it under height so
here's my canvas now I'm gonna link my
HTML file to my JavaScript
I'll go now to my floppy dab flappy bird
Jess I'm gonna just if it works and yes
now let's create our canvas variable to
select the canvas then the context but
now we will load the images so I create
variables different variables for every
image so I'm gonna create one for the
bird and fun for the background one for
the front ground and then are the one
and then two for the pipe now on the
pipes so for all of them they all say
equals the new the object image so for
each one
now I will give them a source then the
SRC equals I'm gonna copy this the last
one is for the pipe south now so I'm
gonna say the images so my follower
images and the birth of PNG all my
images are in the same directory
and the last one I'm gonna check now if
my images are loaded and yes now we will
draw our images so we can set a new
function draw first I'm gonna draw the
the background una cita X and draw image
I'm giving it the background object and
then the exposition on the opposition
and I'm gonna call the draw function now
I'm gonna draw the pipe north and south
so take the draw image to the pipe north
we're gonna use some X&Y positions for
now here's my point now where South and
for the pipe and for the pipe salt we're
gonna add the not pipe that's height
plus the gap so I'm gonna say just
constant and I'm gonna create some
variables right here and see the VAR the
constant here equals the part not that
height plus the gap and the cop acidity
to 70 or 75 pixels I'm gonna copy this
to the bottom and now if i refresh I
will get my pipe South I'm gonna set 80
for the gap or 85 lakhs quit now let's
go and draw the the front ground
obviously takes that
draw image the foreground zero and zero
now if I say zero one zero for the y
position which is at the top so I'm
going to say kind of at that height
minus the phone the ground at height so
it's in its place now I will draw the
bird who
for example ten pixels for the
exposition and 150 for the Y position
now we will change the x and y position
later so I'm gonna say bird X for the
exposition and bird Y for the Y position
I'm gonna change them in my code this
line now our now our bird will well fall
continuously because of the gravity so
we will say the bird y plus and the
gravity so increment it by the gravity
so we will set the gravity two to one
for now
let's refresh now the bird is not moving
so we have to request the animation
frame for the draw function now the bird
is falling go so the erequest animation
here called the drought and the drought
called the request animation and then
it's caused a job again and again and
again
now let's go and now if our player hits
our press okay and the keyboard then the
bird will move up so set a new function
called move up so the bird Y will
decrement by 20 for example for now so
if I hit or if I press ok you see the
bird goes up and then goes down by the
gravity again
now let's go and declare the pipe
coordinates it's an array as we saw
before so I'm gonna save our part equals
an empty array and then pipe then pipe
of zero equals so I'm gonna give it an x
coordinate so the pipe will be there
under y equals zero now we're going to
use the for loop to print or to draw all
the pipes we're gonna copy this inside
the loop and I'm going to change the X
well values with the pipe of I dot X so
this is the x position for every eye in
the pipe array so the pipe knife and the
pipe that has the same positions for the
expositions and here is the Y position
now we'll say pipe of I - - to move to
move the the pipe to the left to draw to
the left here now my pipes are moving to
the to the left now I have to add new
pipes to my array so I'm gonna say F the
pipe of I naught x equals 125 for
example you can use whatever value Wow
I will push a new object to my array
pipe so the x position is always comes
down with it and the Y position
is a random position so we'll use the
math flow and the Matt random x the pipe
north not height - the pipe north that
height and here is the result I have to
change the gravity here so the ground
I'm gonna say 1.5 for the gravity and 25
for the for the move up function to make
things easier so that's good now
now let's detect if there's a collision
so f if there is a collision will reload
the page
now presenting Friday my provision
efficiently huh that's a technical now
come on Chicka dance cool but if I go
through the gap then go through the gap
nothing that happens that's cool
now when our bird hits the before the
front ground it's a game over also so
say if the bird y plus the bird dot
height is greater than or equal to
canvas height minus the front ground
height so whenever it touches the phone
the ground it's a game over now F the
pipe I the x equals a fine we'll
increment the score by one and and we go
and print that to the to the canvas so
I'm gonna give it a stop a color for our
text and a font a font size on the font
family and then we're gonna use 2 2 X
that fell text to print the text our
canvas so here we're giving it the text
to show a string and then the exposition
I'm going to say for up then and then
20 for the wine position now it's at the
top I'm gonna move it to the bottom I'm
gonna say canvas height - 20 now it's at
the bottom now to score increments 2 3
oh that's a game over now let's add some
silence to the game let's first create
audio files so I'm gonna save our fly
when our bird fly will make this
summoned and win the score increment or
we'll use this sound so I'm gonna give
it the source of the files so I'm gonna
say sounds fly does mp3 and then for the
score its skull does mp3 so when I move
up the bird it means when the bird flies
then I will play the the fly sound so
I'm gonna say fly that play and now if
the score increments then we'll say
score that play now you can hear the
sound when I press OK in the keyboard
and win this score increments if I pass
through the gap so this is the guys for
this tutorial